recently in the news the presidents of
Harvard pen and
MIT fail to fully denounce calls for
genocide and that Rose questions about
the influence of Dei programs at
universities and so maybe either looking
at this or zooming out more broadly at
identity politics at universities or
identity politics
wokeism in our culture how big of a
threat is it to our culture to Western
Civilization so obviously I'm going to
say it's a huge threat um the reason
that I think this is a huge threat I
want to give a definition of wokeism
because people are very often accused of
not using wokeism properly or believing
that it's sort of a catch-all phrase I
don't think it's a catch-all term uh I
think that wokeism has its root in
postmodernism which essentially suggests
that every
principle is a reflection of underlying
structures of power and that therefore
any inequality that emerges under such a
system is reflection again of that
structure of power that used to be
applied in sort of marxist ways the
suggestion being that economic
inequality was the result of
misallocation of power in the structure
preserved by a an upper crust of people
who wanted to cram down exploitation on
people that was sort of the Marxist
version of postmodernism and then got
transmuted into sort of a racial version
of postmodernism in which the systems of
the United States are white supremacist
in orientation uh and are perpetuated by
a group of people who are in fact in
favor of the president ation of white
power and white supremacy that is the
generalized theory of critical race
Theory uh as proposed by for example
jeene stefanek and Richard Delgado in
their book on critical race theory that
has taken a softer form that we refer to
as Dei the key in Dei is the e meaning
Equity so Equity is a term that does not
mean equality people mix it up equality
is the idea that we all ought to have
equal rights that we all ought to be
treated equally by the law Equity is the
idea that if there is an inequality that
emerges from any system it is therefore
due to discrimination and the best way
to tell whether somebody has been
victimized is by Dent of their race and
we can tell whether you're a member of
an oppressed group or an oppressor Group
by the intersectional identity that you
carry and by the nature of your group's
success or failure predominantly along
economic and power lines in American
life this means that if one group is
predominantly successful economically
they must be a member of the victimizing
class
and the only corrective for that would
be as I X Kennedy likes to suggest uh
effectively anti-racist policy is racism
in the service of destroying racism uh
that you're going to have to that you're
going to have to you know discriminate
on the basis of race in order to correct
for discrimination that's baked into the
system that's incredibly dangerous it
leads to a victim victimizer narrative
that is unhealthy for individuals and
terrible for societies it relieves
people of individual responsibility and
it destroys the very notion of an
objective metric by which we can decide
meritocracy and meritocracy is the only
system human beings have ever devised
that has positive externalities in
literally any area of life every other
distribution of wealth power done along
other lines that is not having to do
with Merit has negative externalities
every system having to do with Merit has
positive externalities because
presumably the most effective and useful
people are going to succeed under those
systems that's the very basis of a
meritocracy and the externalities of
that mean that other people benefit from
the meritorious and excellent
performance of those people
maybe it would be good to get your
comments your old stomping gr Harvard do
you think the president of Harvard
should have been fired I mean I think
she should have been fired not over the
plagiarism allegations I think she
should have been fired based on her
performance just at that Congressional
hearing uh if if the word black had been
substituted for Jew in in in that
statement by Alise stanic that she was
asking about or trans or or literally
any other any other minority in America
maybe with the exception of asan uh then
the answer would have been very
different coming from cloudy and gay you
know with that said I don't think the
firing of cloud and gay really
accomplishes very much mean I'm I'm did
she get what she deserved sure does that
mean that the underlying Dei Equity
based system has been in any way
severely damaged no I think that this is
a way for universities this Truth For
Liz mcil pen also to
basically throw somebody overboard as
the as the sacrifice to to maintain the
underlying system that that continues to
PR nominated American universities where
they spend literally billions of dollars
every year on Dei initiatives and
diversity h and diversity administrators
and and all of this I mean one of the
cost of Education escalating is in the
massive administrative function that
that is now undertaken by universities
as opposed to tej and and you know cost
of dorms and such you guys probably
agree on a lot of this right kind of
maybe yeah
um I I don't know I don't know what
makes things do this but it feels like
we can never like have a good thing and
then have it end as a good thing uh
things always get taken to their uh
extreme and then we have to fight on
those extremes like I would argue that
back in my day we called it sjw social
justice Warriors before it became woke
um like 2013 onwards whatever like there
are aspects to wokeism that I think are
good like I like the additional
representation that we have in media now
I like how as muches people complain
about the internet and how it's
regulated that there are way more groups
that are represented on the internet
whether we're talking uh X the platform
for formerly known as Twitter or
Facebook or whatever um I think in some
ways or whether we're pushing uh you
know like women's achievements in school
and in in um in the wider Workforce I
think that these are all good things the
issue that you run into is people don't
ever have a stopping point and I think
people kind of get lost in this woke for
woke sake thing where we start to see
these very weird warpings of these like
academic I guess arguments that are used
for really horrible things uh so for
instance I think that you can talk about
in the United States things like white
supremacy or uh things like um
oppression of certain demographics
especially with like Jim Crow laws and
pre- Jim Crow and you can even talk
about effects from that that but then
when you run into this weird world where
we've kind of warped these things so
that like not only is white supremacy
still as present today as it ever has
been well actually uh black people in
other minorities can't even be racist
they don't have the power to because
we're going to use a different
definition of racism and we can only
talk about punching up as opposed to
punching down uh and and we're actually
going to say it's totally okay for these
people to say or do whatever they want
and it's never bad but like white people
who have always been the oppressors even
if you're like a trailer park guy whose
family is addicted to meth you know you
have all this privilege etc etc I think
that you run into these issues where
wokeism it starts off as like a really
good idea and I would argue has achieved
really good things especially in regards
to like women's education everything and
then it just gets so Academia so there's
a word there academic whatever where you
take something and you put it in school
too much and then it comes out as some
Frankenstein you know cancer baby of
like horrible things such that today
when I'm reading stuff and I know Ben is
the same way like if I even hear
somebody say the word like anti-racism
I'm probably ignoring every other thing
you have to say uh if you utter the word
like Colonial anything I'm probably
going to say you probably don't have
anything uh good to say um yeah a lot of
it is just Tak taken way too far but you
know what I will blame on some of this
is I will blame conservatives for some
of this because I think one issue that
happens and I think Ben might even agree
with me here too is I think there
there's two huge problems that have
happened in the United States I think
broadly speaking is that one we become
more different than we ever have been
and two we become more similar than we
ever have been and when I say this what
I mean is that like we're splitting off
into these groups and then these groups
are enforcing this insane homogeneity
between these two separate groups and I
think one of these schisms has been
conservatives reluctancy to participate
in things related to higher uh education
uh so for a long time conservatives are
saying like oh you know the educational
institutions are against us you know
Russ talks about how evil the colleges
are and blah blah blah and then what
happens is is conservatives are less and
less willing to engage in them so then
you get this scenario or this
environment where everybody that's
engaged in uh Academia on the
administrative side are are [__]
insane they're very like even more so to
and I also want to draw a distinction
between like the the administrators and
the faculty because often times when
you're reading story after story after
Story of like all of these insane admins
that are pushing further and further
left usually The Faculty is fighting
against it a lot of the tenure
professors a lot of people in their
departments are saying like hold on well
we actually don't agree with this but I
feel like because conservatives for so
long have demonized these institutions
rather than like critically evaluated
them uh and and tried to like have like
honest critique and engagement that
they've just like completely broken off
and when you only have a bunch of
lefties or righties together all they'll
do is they Veer off like even more into
their insane Direction
I feel like that's a big problem that we
run into in the country to where
conservatives have totally broken off
some conversations broken away from
where they won't participate in them
anymore and then the people that you
have left just run as as far to the left
as possible certainly when you look at
certain institutions I think that one of
the things that people on both sides of
the aisle are constantly looking at is
has the institution suffered such
capture that there is just no capacity
to fix it and when you talk about the
universities I'm not going to blame
conservatives for the failure of the
universities because they haven't been
present in major positions at
universities since effectively the late
1960s you can go read Shelby Steel's
work on this where he talks about how
you know he used to be he's now a
conservative black person he was a
liberal black person at the time he was
actually quite a radical black activist
at the time in the 60s and he he talks
about walking into the office of liberal
administrators who are largely on his
side with regard to civil rights and
being a radical him claiming that the
systems of the University were
inherently broken were inherently wrong
unfixable and he talks about this very
it's a very evocative episode where he's
about how he's smoking and as he's
smoking the ash is growing more and more
and the ash falls down on this very
expensive carpet and the president of
the University who's listening to him
rant and Rave he's he Shelby steel says
I thought he was going to say something
about this I mean I was wrecking like a
thousand carpet in his office being a
jackass and instead I could see him wit
inside I could see him collapse he
didn't have the institutional
credibility or the intelle or or sort of
the spiritual strength to just say
listen I agree with you on some of these
things but you're acting like a jackass
and and what you see in the late 1960s
and early 1970s is in fact the collapse
of these institutions to the point where
by the time I was going to college there
was this radical disproportion between
conservatives and liberals and the
problem is that when it comes to a
system like the universities basically
you have to separate the universities
off into two separate categories one is
stem where the universities are still
pretty damn good and American
universities when it comes to stem are
still leading universities in the world
Harvard's main Creations these days are
coming from actual hard science field
then you have the liberal arts field in
which you basically have a
self-perpetuating Elite because that's
actually how dissertations work if you
have somebody who's very far to the left
and you decide that you're going to
write a dissertation on the history of
American gun rights the chances that
that is going to be approved by your
dissertation adviser are much lower than
if you happen to write something that
tends to agree with the political
positions of your dissertation adviser
now listen I think there are open and
tolerant professors even in the liberal
arts at these universities I went to
these universities right I went to UCLA
I went to Harvard Law School when I was
at Harvard Law School one of my favorite
professors was lonni guier Lonnie Gere
what they tried to appoint her I believe
Secretary of Labor under Clinton and she
was too liberal and she got rejected so
she was like a full-on communist by the
time I went there she was great we had
debates every day it was wonderful she
used to write me recommendations for my
my legal jobs after we left Randall
Kennedy I don't agree with him very much
Randall Kennedy was terrific Professor
there are some professors who are like
this unfortunately there tends to be in
these Echo Chambers more and more
ideological Conformity that is
rigorously enforced and it is by left on
left so for example when I was at
Harvard Law School the president of the
University was another president who
ended up being AED Larry Summers Larry
Summers had been the secretary Treasury
under Bill Clinton and he made the
critical error of suggesting that
perhaps the dir of women in hard
Sciences in prestigious positions was
due to possibly two factors that people
were refusing to talk about one was the
possibility that women actually didn't
want to be in hard Sciences at nearly
the rates that men do which happens to
be true uh and two was the distribution
of stem IQ right which is something that
you certainly were not allowed to talk
about the idea that that the men's bell
curve when it comes to IQ particularly
on stem subjects tends to be shallower
than the women's bell curves when you
get to the very end end of the bell
curve what you tend to see is a lot of
really dumb guys and a lot of really
smart guys and so when you're talking
about the top universities maybe that
has something to do with the
disproportion and he's trying to explain
that to say that our systems are not
discriminating if we end up with more
men than women maybe more men are
applying and more men are qualified
that's that's quite he was outad for
that by a left-wing faculty and and you
know General Alum Network at at Harvard
University so there's a lot to blame
conservatives for for surrendering the
playing field I totally agree that
conservatives should not have
surrendered the playing field in some
institutions colleges were surrendered a
lot earlier than 20 years ago they were
surrendered in the late 1960s early
1970s yeah so I think that um a couple
things so uh one of the big issues that
I have with kind of like this uh I don't
know if we call it era of trumpism or
populism is this total disregard for
institutions and this disconnect from
participation in the system so it's one
of the big things that I F with
progressives about who who cares because
they're all 20 years old they don't vote
anyway um but it's another thing that I
noticed with a lot of people that are uh
Trump voters Trump fans or whatever is
this idea where we say this institution
is uh irrevocably destroyed it it's
irredeemable it can't be saved it can't
nothing that we do can can fix it um and
I think that what that leads people to
doing is one they disconnect further and
then two there's a general hopelessness
when it comes to how Society is like ran
or structured such that you fall into
that populous brain rot of the only
person that can save me is Donald Trump
I can't trust literally anything and I
think that when you start driving people
into that direction all it does is it
further amplifies all the problems that
you're complaining about so that's one
of the reasons why talk about like
conservative participation I want there
to be more conservatives that are trying
to participate in Academia but I feel
like the leading thought or the leading
speaking out against it is basically
saying it's a waste of time it's
completely lost so I I think that the
alternative to that is that the you are
seeing on the right a growth of for
example alternative universities the
worst thing no I I I don't think so at
all I think competition is a great way
of incentivizing some change on on
behalf of universities that may have
forgotten that there's an entire another
side of the aisle in the United States
no no shot I don't believe even I don't
think even you think that first of all
Let Me Clear I think the entire
educational system at the upper levels
if you're not in stem is a complete scam
I think it's a complete waste of money I
think it's a complete waste of time and
I think that it's all all it is is a
formalized very expensive sorting
mechanism for people of IQ that's all it
is people take an SAT you go to a good
school you take four years of [__] I
know I did at UCLA and then we analyze
based on your degree where you should go
to law school I could have gone directly
from high school to law school with
maybe one year of training and then done
one year of law school and been done
okay the reality is that this is a giant
scam and this again is by part of
problem but it's just a generalized
problem the we we have and you want to
talk about things that hurt the lower
classes in the United States the
bleeding of degrees up is so wild and
crazy there's so many jobs in the United
States that should not require a college
degree that we now require a college
degree to do because there was this
weird idea that came over Americans
where they mistook correlation for
causation they would say oh look people
who go to college are making more money
than people who don't go to college
therefore everyone should go to college
well maybe the reason is because people
who are going to college were better
qualified for particular jobs because on
average not all the time but on average
a lot of those people were smarter and
making more money because of that and so
all you've done is you've now created
these additional layers of
stratification so a person who used to
be able to get a job with a college
degree now has to have a postdoc degree
in order to go get that degree a person
who used to be able to just graduate
high school now it's the facto you got
to go to Juco and then you got to go to
college or nobody's even going to look
at your resume it's really really
terrible for people who can't afford all
of that it's led to this massive
increase in educational cost that is
inexplicable other than this particular
sort of bleed up and by the way Federal
subsid for higher education again one of
my problems with Federal subsidies for
higher education I'd love for everyone
to be able to go to college if qualified
to do so and if it is productive but one
of the things I did when I went to law
school is I took loans because a bank
said I was going to get my money back if
I got a law degree from Harvard but you
know when you're not going to get your
money back if you're a bank you're not
going to lend to some dude who wants to
major in you know art Theory because is
that a good bet there's no collateral
right if I give a loan for a house I can
go repossess the house how do I
repossess your garbage college degree
from UCLA there's no way to do that so
you know one one of my so yeah this is
the broader conversation about education
in general I think the educational
system is cruising for a bruising and I
think all that's necessary for it to
completely collapse on the non- stem
side where you actually learn things is
for people who employ to Simply say give
me your SAT score and I will hire you
for an apprenticeship directly out of
high school that it would cut out so
much of the middleman but as far as the
general point that you're making about
institutions I I may disagree on the
education and how far it's gone in
general I agree with you so it's in in
general I agree and I get to use my my
favorite longest word in the English
language here I I would consider myself
in many cases an anti-is
establishmentarian nice right you see I
like to drop that that's because if
you're an establishmentarian that means
you like establishmentarian so I'm anti
can you say that word d that's the one
we all learned growing up anti dis
establishment Terr
longest and then some kid in your group
say what about super Calif fragile and
then you what about num microscopic or
the science terms or what about the
7,000 letter thing that's from part of
uh biochem I got my education the Soviet
Union so we just did math didn't this
that's why you're a useful person Soviet
Union math was that one plus one how to
make that equal three we know long words
and he streams on the
internet and and I talk for living so
anyway the but the the point is that I
don't disagree that there is a general
populist tendency on all sides of the
aisle to look at the institutions and
then throw them overboard I think that
some of that is earned by people who are
in positions of power at institutions
who have completely undermined the faith
and credibility of those institutions I
think you have to examine institution by
institutions which ones are salvageable
and which ones are not so I'm not a a
full anti- disestablishmentarianism I'd
be partially in that camp there are
certain institutions like higher
education in the liberal arts that I
think we may be better off without and
then there are certain institutions like
say participation in American government
where when people talk about we need a
revolution like no we don't that's not a
thing we need an evolution we need
change we need we can use the system and
and you know but I think you have to
Esta you have to look at it industry by
industry you know by institution on that
position on institions do you think
Biden or Trump would side would you more
uh as far as the institutions I think
the institutions in the United States at
the governmental level are robust I
think the social institutions are fair
yeah but I'm just curious on your
general view of Institutions do you
think Biden or Trump would saage you
more on how you view them um I mean I
think that in rhetoric Biden would and
then I think that he would tear out the
face of the institutional wear it around
like a masc like cannibal leor I mean
that's resisted some people's calls to
like pack the court and uh yes because I
think that his use of executive power
was greater than that of Donald Trump
the power that he had he used to Greater
effect than Donald Trump Donald Trump
again thrashed up against the sides of
the box but could not get out of it okay
um for just real quick because on the
that that answer went a lot further than
the initial but yeah just on the real
quick thing the reason why I again my
main problem that I feel like we have
today in society is people are getting
into their own bubbles the idea of
having like conservative schools and
liberal schools seems like the saddest
thing in the world to me like I would
want conservatives and liberals going to
school together because I think these
people need to interact with each other
more if for no other reason than to see
that the other person is not like an
actual monstrous horrible entity that
want to destroy the country listen I
think a classically liberal idea for
many schools would not be a bad thing I
think it would be a good thing I just
wonder if that's salvageable and if it's
not salvageable then the answer to that
is to actually create alternative feel
like I feel like the biggest issue that
we have is people are they sort into
these different like Phantom worlds to
where even if you live in the same city
there are totally different worlds that
exist between liberals and conservatives
and I feel like one of the big barriers
to people understanding the other side
sometimes it's just a little bit of
information or a little bit of like
firsthand experience um when I so in
terms of information sure you saw um I
don't I don't know if this is a full-on
study but they were talking about how
some huge percentage of students would
change their mind on from The River To
The Sea when you told them what from the
river what the river was and what the
was yeah or when you said like yeah what
does a one state solution mean a lot of
them like such that the numbers went
from like 70% to like 30% in terms of
like support um would fall and it wasn't
because you were doing a radical
redefining their whole ideology you were
just giving them a little bit more
information um and then something that
I've seen on a firstand level is when I
go and speak or do debates at University
sometimes I'm in very very very
conservative areas some of my fans are
are trans having like a transperson show
up and talk to conservatives for a
little bit uh not like in a speech but
just like in a in like a bar or a
setting like a lot of them walk away
they like oh not every transperson is
like this insane lunatic from Twitter
that is [__] an actual crazy person
and then for some of my fans when they
hang out with conservatives like oh
these guys are actually pretty friendly
I thought they would have all been
homophobic racist transic and evil but
they're not they're just like normal
people I feel like we need more of that
I totally agree with that certainly yeah
and I feel like on our social media
platforms on our algorithms and our
schools I feel like we're sorting harder
and harder and harder and any type of
rhetoric that encourages the Sorting is
really bad and damag we need to like
continue to mix up and there's other
things I want to talk about opening his
mouthy the uniter wow all right as we
not like
Trump